rewrite the following equation in
logarithmic form so they wrote they have
100 is equal to 10 to the second power
so if we want to write the same
information really in logarithmic form
we could say
that
the power the power that i need to raise
10 to
to get to 100 is equal to 2 or log
log base 10
of
is equal to
2. notice these are equivalent
statements this is just an exponential
form this is in logarithmic form this is
saying the l the power that i need to
raise 10 to to get to 100 is equal to 2
which is the same thing as saying that
ten to the second power is a hundred ten
to the second power is a hundred and the
way that i specified the base is by
doing this underscore right over here so
underscore ten log base ten of a hundred
is equal to two
now they here they ask us to rewrite the
following equation in exponential form
so this is log base 5 of 1 over 125 is
equal to negative 3.
this is a one way to think about is this
saying the power that i need to raise 5
2 to get to 1 over 125
is equal to negative 3 or
that 5
to the
negative 3 power
5 to the negative 3 power is equal to 1
over 125 and we can verify that this has
formatted it the right way 5 to the
negative 3 power is 1 over 125 the exact
same truth about the universe just in
different forms logarithmic form and
exponential form so let me check my
answer make sure i got it right and i
did